eu general affairs ministers will  finalize preparations for the european  council on march 2021.  they will also take note of a presidency  synthesis report  on the main messages of the different  council configurations  in relation to the 2014 european  semester  during the spring european council eu  heads of state and government are  expected to conclude the first phase of  the european semester  and to discuss how to foster industrial  competitiveness  they will also have a first policy  debate on a new framework for climate  and energy  on the external relations front  preparations for the upcoming eu africa  summit  and the situation in ukraine will take  the center stage  ministers will also take stock of the  commission's communication on the rule  of law mechanism  a new framework has been adopted by the  commission for addressing systemic  threats to the rule of law in member  states  it establishes an early warning tool to  prevent the escalation of infringements  on eu law